good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday everyone
hope you're all having a blessed and
Juicy and Delicious and scrumptious hump
day speaking of scrumptious hey Jax how
you doing I'm darn good thanks for
asking that's a really sensual intro
have you been watching too much of the
idol I actually have not seen even one
mere minute of the idol and based on
everyone's reactions I feel as though
I've made the right decision I was
chuckling yesterday at your episode with
the Satchel when you guys were going
quote for quote it did you die I would I
was dying honestly I'm like grateful
that I had that story when um counselor
was on because like we can laugh about
it you would have like not been okay if
we had to say that like yeah no but I
thought you guys said it really
Tastefully I understood the words that
you were
meaning skirting around yeah I thought
you guys handled it like a bunch of Pros
with grace and elegance you would say
with grace and elegance but I would
expect nothing less you know what was
not graceful and elegant what the period
talk ladies yeah so we we kind of go
wild when you're out like all the rule
the rule book is thrown out the window
when Jax is taking a day off and that
means we just go kind of crazy yeah it
was a lot of period
it actually like wasn't a lot of period
[Music]
I hope the mic picked that up I hope the
mic picked it up too I think it did
um screaming for Mama
uh you know it wasn't a lot it was just
like more than
what we do listen I probably say this on
a monthly basis I feel like I feel like
you guys are like if I never said
anything about yes yes talking about
periods like you wouldn't feel the need
to talk about them but it's because I
told you you can't that now you're like
rebelling and it's like oh she's not
here let's talk about periods and I
swear I say this once a month because
that's how periods work but I do feel as
though it's important when the listeners
know that I am on my period like if
people are like wow Claudia was like
kind of rude today like yeah Mommy
period [__] all the way off that part I
do understand yeah I just feel like when
when people know us as intimately as
they do spend an hour with us every day
if a couple days a month I'm like not
being myself there is a an actual
biological reason and to not let people
know that is to not let them know the
full story and that's not me being a
transparent and authentic influencer you
know what you're speaking facts I'm
feeling convinced
you know you ever get comments people
being like were you okay today like no
[__] I was on my period okay yeah yeah
not for me like I've had three periods
in the last two years but yeah so funny
enough I was actually thinking about
your menstrual cycle on my way to dinner
last night just thinking like how many
periods has this [__] had in the last
two years so I had three periods
I can't believe you brought me down to
your level no but you know what Jackie
we are podcasts that uplifts women and
you know what women get periods
it's true okay so I had I had three
periods in between pregnancies because I
didn't get my period while I was
breastfeeding
right right right wow so you've had
three periods in the last two years and
that's why you get pregnant and that's
how Sue sees it no but I would say that
the hormonal changes and bodily changes
that come with pregnancy are much more
extreme than just a little period so
when I hear you [__] the hairy [__]
is complaining I'm like sure
sure sure
um listen you know all of our problems
are problems you know are valid are
valid yes yeah
um
I went to a fabulous restaurant last
night like a new Hot Spot in town it was
so cute it was so good it was called
Theresa and it was just like a gorgeous
Night Out in NYC I really felt like
Harry Bradshaw like running around in my
kitten heels were you wearing kitten
heels I was wearing like a like a block
sandal so yeah they were like a little
kitten cute yeah what'd you eat such a
good question
I had this it was like you know Tapas
style like you just get like a bunch of
little things and everybody shares it so
me and Brian he got like a bunch of
appetizers that weren't just not at my
vibe like this oyster cake it was just
not gonna happen for me
um but for entrees we got a tortellini
Pomodoro which was um scrumdily I'm sure
sounds of rich and we split um the
chicken it was very good
great yeah I love discovering new places
in my hometown where was the restaurant
located Mulberry Street wow
wow I went all the way down
she went downtown
downtown and then I came home watched
1989 World Tour a little bit of young
Sheldon and went to sleep I finished
Love and Death last night oh my God what
did you think I thought it was really
good so crazy spoiler alert yeah spoiler
alert that she was not guilty but
she wasn't guilty that was the thing and
that's what I feel like the show did a
good job of like she was nuts and she
was so wrong for sleeping with that
girl's husband but in the actual crime
it was self-defense like Betty brought
the ax out not once but twice Betty
swung first but the thing is like we
still only have her version of events
yes and so the show really did like
obviously take her side because they
showed us her version of events as the
truth that like Betty swung first
so I guess we just all have to believe
that and also like if it was
self-defense like why didn't she just
call the cops and why did she leave the
baby in the duty all day oh my God okay
unacceptable that should be there should
be jail time for that that episode gave
me such bad anxiety and they were all
looking for Betty it's like yeah of
course Betty but the baby I was like
well you know Candy's a mom she probably
like changed her diaper put the kid down
give him a snack before she left like
that's literally what I thought because
I'm like there's no way and then I was
like the baby the baby the baby and then
they finally like addressed the baby
when all those neighbors and you know
what I feel like that episode was a
really good
um example of why you should always be
nice and know your neighbors yeah that
for sure but also there needs to be a
crime for her leaving a baby alone
unattended for like for like 12 hours a
hundred percent I completely agree jail
time I also thought one of the craziest
parts and then a separate jail time for
Cavaliers
for the Cavaliers left to band and the
shredder and thank God they had each
other thank God they had each other and
they got they were outside so they could
like [__] and poop but then they
wouldn't be hungry the body oh my God
totally but either strikes would never
he would never eat his mommy
I thought also one of the crazier Parts
was the end where they you know gave
updates on what happened to everyone in
real life after the trial wrapped and
the lawyer who ran for governor and then
ended up committing suicide I was like
shook yeah
I thought candy and him were gonna end
up together because they were both kind
of like diabolical yeah they were really
crazy
really crazy I thought um everyone's
like it was really Emmy worthy acting
for Landry for Elizabeth the only thing
about Landry is that like to me he's so
lovable Landry the man that he made Alan
Gore really likable
whereas then even in the small snippet
they gave us about him at the end of the
show that like he remarried soon after
the grandparents adopted the kids so he
didn't he wasn't even a father like
maybe he wasn't like the best guy
because I weirdly was feeling like even
though he's cheating on his wife like
he's still looking at us but no no I
know he was like
he was kind of harmless even though he
was doing harmful things and I really
did feel like she totally like wrote I
mean she did rope him into the affair
like she's like
it would have been so hard for him to
say no and it and he tried to say no for
so long and then even that night when he
like knew something was up with Betty
and he kept calling the house
oh my God go home no I was just like
well you don't expect that it's the
absolute worst thing
yeah and I also guess like if that
happened today everyone would be like
quaking but with nobody had unless you
were home you couldn't be reached by
phone yeah but like if you're like an
absent husband like you don't notice if
you don't hear your wife for 12 hours
yeah so when he like kept calling the
house I was just like you know what in
his own weird way he is a good husband
yeah yeah yeah
um I did feel like there was just one
kind of like loose end that I was
confused on okay
um how when Alan stood trial like he
kind of lied when he said the affair
like ended completely clean candy didn't
want anything else from him like
candy did like candy was vocal about her
feelings for him and like he just
couldn't take the plunge I felt like he
lied
well I feel like candy in her like Soul
was like kind of wanting more and she
would talk to Sherry and like we knew
that she was like just saying certain
things but didn't mean them but to Alan
like she tried oh I guess they had that
fight in the diner and then in the park
hmm yeah but it did end and then ended
like maybe when it ended yeah it was
like a breakup combo but then like it
was eight months later and it wasn't
like she was following him around town
how like sad and cute and sweet was Pat
yeah
like at first he was kind of the villain
because he wasn't like the most adoring
doting husband but then like when [__]
got rough and she was like still so
terrible to him he was such a good
husband and Dad and the fact that they
ended up getting divorced is not
surprising but like it was sad yeah not
surprising it was a really good show it
was a good show we enjoyed it it was
like a perfect length I didn't need any
more than that seven episodes I don't
know what's next for me but I've been
reading a lot I think I'll wait to get
into like another bingy show because
also like I just hate the feeling of
when you're sewing a show that like you
just keep wanting to run back to the TV
and watch and it's like there's life to
be lived you know there's children to
parent yeah there's bed to be rested on
I don't ever thought like I can't be
watching TV all day yeah yeah I actually
didn't watch any TV yesterday I was just
like so booked and busy I went to the
dentist finally I've just been like
putting that off got my teeth cleaned
I'm feeling good I'm feeling fresh your
shiny teeth and you imagine me yeah
they look nice and shiny thanks that's
the thing about teeth cleaning like you
you get out of the chair and you expect
to like look like Vanna White you know
like new veneers and they really look
the same because like cleanliness is not
about color yeah it's that is very true
and they were like you want us to polish
I was like oh yeah give me a Polish I
was like I'm gonna walk out like but
like Ross when he gets his teeth white
and like blinding people in the streets
no
TIG you talk to your dentist about
whether veneers are right for you I
didn't although he is a cosmetic dentist
so I know that like if I want to you
know change my whole face and get
veneers one day I will be going to him
but you know I have so many issues with
my body and shockingly my teeth are not
one of them like yeah my teeth aren't
like Perfection like veneers but they're
literally fine yeah
but they're just like and for me too I
just feel like excuse me no this is for
this goes for me too I feel like until
you have veneers you don't have adult
teeth
I actually I'm like refusing to
subscribe to this like Hollywood
narrative this beauty standard for
veneers like no you you can be beautiful
and have like normal teeth my teeth are
so normal watch I'm literally gonna
replay this episode in a year when I
have like a full set of veneers I think
it's so immature we had this
conversation like a year ago yeah I
don't know if we'll ever get veneers but
the thing is I don't know I feel like
sometimes like we're like George
Washington just like running around with
our Naturals who do we think we are no I
know we're so natural we're so George
but the thing is I don't really see a
world in which I do get veneers because
a like I I just genuinely like think
it's too expensive and B it's the
longest most painful procedure where
you're like fully awake for it like
honestly no
okay
like I have such a low tolerance to like
put up with pain and just tedious like
no yeah like I plan on getting a breast
augmentation one day and yeah I know
that's really painful but I'm asleep
[__] like bye no and like that's that's
worth it that's been bothering you just
to get veneers just to keep up you're
like trying to Goat me into getting
veneers and like I'm not I'm gonna be
I'm George till the day I die
yeah no I'm not trying to go you I'm
just it's kind of just like the elephant
in the room with us that we like walk
around with our natural teeth and but
like doesn't everyone
like I refuse to be I will not be
insecure about my teeth like my teeth
are fine
yeah and you can always just keep your
mouth closed but that's really good no
if there's like a list of things I want
to change on my body I would say teeth
30.
okay like I don't even think about my
teeth ever I see a picture of my
gorgeous smile that girl has yeah
I don't think about my teeth ever but
maybe I should be thinking about them
more no you shouldn't like no no I I
mean I shouldn't and I won't be
I'm just saying no don't just say we're
fine okay
then me
so we've got a great show today we've
got stories we've got deer toasters and
two of them really made me chuckle when
I was reading them this morning so I
can't wait to give we're I'll give a
little teaser okay so you know you don't
drop off but before the end of the
episode there is a situation
um and I think it's a it's a kind of a
divisive topic about people who kiss
their parents on the lips
okay
and we'll talk about it more okay can't
wait to talk about that I haven't done
deer toasters in a few weeks so I'm
excited to help our girlies oh yeah I
love doing deer trousers with you like
no one no one knows no one rules with an
iron fist quite like Jax so true
although I will say last week Joey
camouse actually did give some like I
expected him to be like funny and crazy
but he also gave some like actually
really good advice Joey come ask is like
kind of Hamish
Joey Grace is like kind of everything
well that's true yeah
so I guess anything else you want to
chit chat about before we dive in no I
think I'm all caught up okay and I'm
looking forward
to what stories have to bring for us in
actually wait wait sorry before we get
into that last night I was driving to
dinner and I passed a restaurant called
mama do's kitchen and I'm like Theo's
mom has a restaurant
you got to keep him far away I think we
should do a patreon where we go and eat
there mama do daddy do you know what
kind of food it was no I just drove
right past it Mama dues I feel like Ben
would go there it was giving like
All-American I think the sign had like a
picnic table pattern like it was giving
Berry barbecue like All-American box was
do spelled d-u or d-o
d u o so it was authentic
how is do
amazing like just lifting are you gonna
bring him over today
sure yeah right yeah for the shredder in
let's let's
[Music]
try Spruce see
it's such a good song I know
it's a day of a reckoning who sings that
Martina McBride [__] Queen like a
question sorry I'm I think no it's
definitely giving Martina McBride but
there's like a few country women who
like give Martina McBride energy you
know Sarah Mclaughlin is another one I
disagree I think she kind of stands
alone Martina McBride no I'm sorry Sarah
Mclaughlin is ASPCA hold on freedom and
that's not song Martina
let the white of sing Let the whole
world know that Martina what's this song
called Independence Independence Day
yeah but there's actually like a few
songs called Independence Day and
they're all so good you're Independence
Day yeah that's like if you title your
song independence day it'll probably be
good what do you think is the number one
Martina McBride song
the one about this one's for the girls
yep I agree this one's for the girls
yeah it's so good now I'm on Martina
McBride's Wikipedia she has three
children beautiful daughters she's 56.
you're on making a McBride are you okay
matina you're on Martina McBride Tick
Tock literally
she's 56 she's a Leo and it's actually
uh Independence Day is Martina McBride
and Pat Benatar song
huh
the more you know the more you know
now
without further Ado
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
kiwico kiwico believes that every kid is
naturally creative and curious and that
Hands-On experiences build creative
confidence and problem-solving skills
that can change the world so kiwico
delivers seriously fun learning for kids
of all ages whether it's about science
or sensory play games or geography every
crate from kiwico is designed by their
team and expert inspires excitement
curiosity and moments of Discovery so
you know we got to keep our kids
entertained we don't want to just throw
them in front of a screen for hours a
day and that's where kiwico comes in
because they're making learning fun and
they are delivering fun Hands-On
projects that inspire a lifelong love of
learning so their projects are sparking
creative confidence for ongoing
tinkering and experimentation yeah you
can buy a robot but isn't it way more
fun to build one their crates are
designed by experts so they're designed
by a team of Educators makers engineers
and Rocket scientists and they're tested
and approved by kids it's hard to find
creative ways to keep the kids in your
life busy Challenge and off their
screens so no crate from kiwico's
Innovation Factory leaves without
approval from one of their toughest
critics the kids of course so it's
delivered monthly
um there's something for kids of all
ages from infants and preschoolers to
teens and Beyond and there's no
commitment so you can pause or cancel at
any time redefine learning with play
explore Hands-On projects that build
creative confidence with kiwico get 50
off your first month plus free shipping
on any crate line at kiwico.com
toast that's 50 off your first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com slash toast today's
episode is also brought to you by the
perfect bar the original refrigerated
protein bar that you know we love if you
haven't heard perfect bar just launched
a new line of protein bars called the
perfect bar layers perfect bar layers
are a new line of crispy crispy protein
bars that are stacked with three
delicious layers and packed with whole
food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut and cashew butter
they're layered with dark chocolate or
100 real fruit and then they're
sprinkled with toasted gluten-free oats
additionally They are packed with up to
11 grams of protein and they come in two
delicious flavors crispy peanut butter
and chocolate and crispy peanut butter
and Berry so it's basically like a
healthy peanut butter jelly because
they're made with only whole food
ingredients their classic blend of 20
organic superfoods they contain no
artificial preservatives which means the
perfect bars are stored in the fridge so
you could say these bars are stacked and
packed if you haven't already been
convinced there are also non-GMO project
verified they're gluten free they are
soy free they are Kosher and they are
low GI and the best part is that you can
now find them in the refrigerated
section at Target for all of our Target
girlies don't forget to stock up on your
perfect bars keep them in the fridge
your husband will need them take them
before work take them to the gym perfect
bar knows that it'll be Love At First
Bite so they're offering you a chance to
try their new refrigerated protein bars
for free here's how it works sign up for
email or text and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar it'll go directly into
your venmo or PayPal account which is
pretty cool all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thanks Claudia
I ate the perfect bar yesterday
of course you did because you're a
perfect human being oh my
oh my you are you drinking from a
Stanley
you don't know I have a Stanley Cup I
didn't know you have a Stanley Cup
you're supposed to talk about it all the
time if you have one well let me tell
you I had uh I like wanted a water
bottle like when I
maybe like now it's almost been a year
yeah like when I started like wanting to
get healthy I was like I know I need to
start drinking more water so I bought
one and I was like gonna buy Stanley
because that's what everyone had I'm
like not this thing being like 60 for a
water bottle so I went on Amazon and I
just bought like a bottle with a straw
from like simple human it was literally
twelve dollars and it was amazing and I
had no problems with it I kept my
beverages cold then when I just did I
went on a brand trip and in like the
little gift bag there was a Stanley I
was like oh well now I can be like all
the girls and this one was like cool
neon one so I brought it home with me
and I've been using it ever since and
you know what it really is that [__]
like it keeps that [__] ice cold like
this water's from last night and it's
freezing wow I kind of need a Stanley
because I need to be drinking more water
I was actually just gonna get a water
bottle on Amazon like get one of the
ones that are like hourly like those
crazy ones but I need a crazy one I just
need something that's gonna make it more
fun for me to drink water and through a
straw because then I'll drink like more
passively yes
you could sprinkle like a little Crystal
Light in there because Crystal Light is
drinking water it totally counts yeah no
it does I just have to like look at what
it's made of but yeah yeah because
you're like in your clean girl era but I
feel like Crystal would never do that to
us I feel like Crystal would do exactly
that like crystal is fake as [__] okay
but there are also like Crystal Light
Alternatives like these new wave like
Mio like all these like new clean ones
yeah yeah or I could just like squeeze
the lemon in there call it a day you
know I've done that too I do love a
lemon water yeah
okay I think I'm gonna stand after this
I've been influenced influenturity luja
I do have like one problem with the
Stanley and if you have a Stanley you
know what I'm talking about because like
oh actually I guess right now no never
mind how often do you wash it
every time I go to refill it so like
every few days do you can you put in the
dishwasher
I don't know I never have I just do a
soap and a sponge and I move on with my
life because there's just water in there
not Duty you know but I just like hate
hand washing stuff oh really I actually
prefer hand washing stuff because if I
throw something in the dishwasher like I
will never see it again like I this is
what I do I'll I'll load up the dish the
dishwasher like for a few days because
I'm not gonna wash like three bowls so
when there's enough stuff so let's say I
put my my Stanley in on Monday
I probably won't run the dishwasher
until Wednesday
and then I probably won't unload the
dishwasher
until Friday because Thursday I will be
like oh I forgot to unload the
dishwasher and then I'll open up the
dishwasher I'm like you've all just been
like sitting in here let me run it again
and then by Friday I pull it out so it's
like then I'm left five days without my
Stanley if I need something like if it's
I have like also this like glass mason
jar thing that I drink my coffee in like
I I literally do not uh dishwash it I
hand wash it if I need something I
cannot put it in the dishwasher the
dishwasher is a black hole that is at
home when I'm like home home I run my
dishwasher like once or twice a day so
it's not an issue but here like we have
less dishes so yeah if I put something
in the dishwasher like I literally I
think you won't see it for a week it's
still in there I don't know the last
time we actually ran the dishwasher
because it's not full I hate like
dishwash I don't believe in dishwashers
like there are certain years I'm the
polar like I can't speak right now
because right now I'm not living like in
my truth but at home like everything
goes in the dishwasher no I and I
literally like when I'm buying something
new
on Amazon or something like I have to
make sure it's dishwasher safe otherwise
I'm not getting it no I wouldn't know if
the Stanley's dishwasher safe or not it
has literally never been in the
dishwasher but I have to imagine it's
dishwasher safe I don't know some things
are dishwasher safe it's fine but it
like chips away at the Integrity of the
thing like caramel yeah yeah I'm okay
with hand washing like because it's
worth it I hand wash all my pants like
if because I need a pan to cook and if I
put in the dishwasher I'll never see her
again
that's really funny yeah
okay well now that we've covered that
let's get into the stories I think we
should first up stassi shorter is giving
us a look inside Ariana and Katie's
sandwich shop something about her
so the other night Saucy posted on
Instagram she went to stop something
about her with Katie Lala and Christina
Kelly and they got The Grand Tour and
like the restaurant is done so we saw
the outside it has like this yellow and
white striped awning super cute and then
the inside is so as they described like
Nancy Meyer girly swirly it's really as
it's like Parisian too yeah honestly it
looks like stassi designed it I by the
way Jackie I thought the same thing it
looked like stassi's aesthetic in a wall
between like those framed pictures very
like Marie Antoinette
um now if you were you know an active
user on Tick Tock you would have saw the
interior of something about her like
weeks ago because there's this guy who
literally goes to West Hollywood every
day and like puts his phone up against
the window and we you saw all the
furniture like so I had seen this before
but I actually hadn't seen that wall
that stassi had panned to in her
Instagram story and it was really very
well done yeah it was really well done
I'm sure they're opening soon I think
someone said this in like the comments
of our thing which I guess makes
essential way to open until they're
filming yeah even though they did say
before this whole
shebang was that um end of May early
June which has passed yeah but they're
ready to open it looks like actually you
never know what's going on in the
kitchen just like Schwartz and Sandy's
looked ready for a while but it wasn't
but it didn't like really look ready too
it was like kind of like debunked yeah
but also making sandwiches is different
than like a whole ass menu bar no this
was like I thought this was a smart idea
prior to scandival but now that like
everyone's team Katie and Ariana it's
obviously an even better idea but like
such a low lift I think they only they
don't have a bar they might serve wine
but like not hard liquor
um it's such a low lift and it's very
smart yeah I'm excited for them and I
think they were actually able because
you know they were like looking for
investors I think they were able to fund
it themselves because it's like a
smaller project and they did all that
merch and stuff to like
I hope so that's like that's kind of
major yeah did they say they made 200
000 in the merch yes right so I don't
know how much it takes to open a
sandwich shop but I feel like they're in
the ballpark especially and then if they
both come to the table with like a
hundred grand each personally to invest
in their business
um yeah I don't know how much it costs
but it's a it's a small spot it has like
a little cute patio in the front I hear
there's also a back patio this is what a
guy on Tick Tock said
um so it's not like a huge project it
was actually you know it's it's very
legitimate yeah and also what's so crazy
is if you remember like Katie originally
wanted to open the sandwich shop with
Tom like years ago and he chose to do
swarths and Sandy's yeah and then she
you know mentioned it to Ariana and
Ariana love the idea but like if Tom had
played his cards differently and
correctly
he'd be in a much different position I
also just want to say like for the
record I still don't really like the
name
yeah
um I don't know what it should be called
but I just don't something about her
sounds like you know a line of clothing
free people would make like I don't know
there's just but that seems like the
vibe but that's not living for like a
restaurant like hey you want to go grab
lunch at you know Subway or something
like you want to go grab lunch at
something about her it's like a little
long
I don't disagree
yeah like like
you want to grab Jersey Mike's but it
doesn't actively bother me
it actively bothers me
but they said it would be like there's
it's something about her sandwiches you
know
oh something about her sandwiches like
like when you're talking about the
sandwiches you're like there's something
about her sandwiches
Oh I thought you meant like there's
something about her sandwiches yeah yeah
yeah no like it's a double entender it's
like a play on words okay we by the way
I see that yeah it's like it's
I can't think of a word for it but it's
just a little like nice fairy dust
yeah it's not my favorite
okay well maybe one day we'll go to La
and we can go get sandwiches that's the
other thing like I wish I could enjoy
like I don't even like sandwiches maybe
they'll franchise but what do you mean
they might have a nice sourdough
if they have like a peanut butter and
jelly
I'm sure that they will have an elevated
peanut butter and jelly even though or
like a grill elevated grilled cheese
probably for sure yeah fire sure what
about a grilled chicken sandwich
love a grilled chicken sandwich I think
you should give it
I will
I love when do you think we'll go to La
again
we I don't know me probably sometime in
the next few months but you I don't know
we L.A steens La week La week you know
I'm always down like we work around your
ovulation and menstrual cycles it's true
but I also feel like with us in La like
it's always a last minute Affair like we
don't make plans to go at the la la just
kind of summons us yeah it's like yeah I
like Hollywood calls Hollywood calls and
we pick up yeah so who knows when we'll
go to La could be next week well
actually it could be next week it
actually can't be next week but no like
we know it won't be for like the next
six months at least yeah yeah
so we'll say no me I love La more
Jackie weirdly like loves la like I
think you would live there I think I
would no I wouldn't
I wouldn't live there
but I like going there so much like
people complain so much when they go
there but the people are just like I
don't know stuff I like everything about
it when I go
I I don't
but I'm also just like a hater to my
core you know because you hate the
people
I don't like the people I don't have
like ah
I just don't like the culture you know
the yeah like the matcha hike culture
Rome turtle
no I did I hiked Iranian Canyon whatever
it's called Runyan
it was one of the worst days of my life
that's weird that you did that why
didn't you yeah because that was with
like two skinny [__] who wanted to do
it I literally sat down on a bench
halfway and they like went up and then
came back down and picked me up on the
way down I was like I'm done with this
[__] who were you with Alicia and Anna
damn
we were like be doing La things they're
like Runyon Canyon I'm like okay no
that's crazy yeah that you did that yeah
I could never get you to do that yeah
well they're ready for our next story
yeah
because it's
has to do with something we were talking
about on Monday models getting married
to eligible men Victoria's Secret Angel
Taylor Hill married her quote best
friend Daniel fryer on a Colorado Ranch
obsessed Taylor Hill married the love of
her life and best friend private Equity
investor Daniel fryer near her hometown
at the 6500 Acres I love when you when
your best friend just also happens to be
like a private investor in Equity Bank
divider or whatever you said yeah a
private Equity investor I just kind of
love when that happens they got married
at the Devil's Thumb Ranch and Resort in
Colorado last Saturday uh the bride
originally met her husband who's London
born in Geneva raised at jazz fest in
Aspen in 2019 and he popped the question
two years later in Italy with a large
emerald cut try diamond ring
this wedding is like so Pinterest but
like in a really good way you know what
it reminds me of it reminds me of um
1929 the show like that yes the vibe I
loved her look I loved everything about
it like they really bloomed where they
were planted it was very Colorado
mountainous but and she was very uh
Whimsical and Bohemian but in a really
nice looking way it was beautiful yeah
it was very yellow stone coated it was
not like crazy ostentatious but it was
really beautiful and tasteful like you
can tell it costs a lot of money but
it's not because there was like gold
dripping from the centerpieces like it
was really tasteful she's so beautiful I
loved like how he's like this foreign
businessman but they had this like
All-American wedding I'm obsessed and
her dress obsessed obsessed like I feel
like it's actually not getting as much
attention as it deserves this way
because people are kind of stumbling
upon it but it's not like you know
headline news and now it's getting like
more attention because people are
genuinely interested and like what's
just like a cute couple like she's 27
he's 29. so normal so normal I'm
obsessed no they definitely go in my
Jasmine Tukes Miranda Kerr category like
I need to learn more about him and like
his you know background and finances but
I'm shipping I'm here for it they're in
the category like that's an elite
wedding Elite marriage Elite coupling
Elite everything yeah and were there
even any Seas there that you saw
fellow models Taylor Hill's like a real
she's like really a supermodel yeah
but like her bridal party was normies
love to see it so yeah just like normal
yeah but like normal normal but everyone
is so beautiful and Rich yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was really spectacular I love a
wedding like this and you know it kind
of reminds me like the last wedding we
were really obsessed with I forgot about
them they're also an elite marriage Kate
Bach and Kevin Love yeah except he is uh
athlete NBA player like a businessman
um but also Sophia Richie and Elliot oh
yeah oh that's a great businessman he's
like a model
in tastemaker amongst other things and
he's a business Mambo
yeah no the girlies are like out here
making good marriages like I feel like
we're all over like dating like actors
and athletes like they just break your
hearts like find a rich private citizen
you will live a much happier life hard
working
nepo baby I'm down like you know family
money
it's good yeah it's nice I'm happy for
them this was a really gorgeous wedding
Vogue also like it was the photographs
were amazing it was so so high brow so
elegant but like not in a tacky way at
all yeah and when her dress was like
really interesting so it was very it was
gorgeous but it was very like
simple Pilgrim yeah but like oh yeah
supermodels amazing and she like it I
feel like I rarely see a wedding dress
that's like something new yeah or like
something different that's unexpected
and I just I really liked it I agree
are you ready for our next story I am
the weekend is defending his douchebag
characters gluttonous sex scene in the
idol following the backlash that turdy
Lou and Margot described yesterday
so the weekend defended his despicable
character on the highly controversial
HBO series the idol after a graphic sex
scene left viewers and sisters horrified
he spoke to GQ on Tuesday and said
there's nothing sexy about it however
you're feeling watching that scene
whether it's discomfort or you feel
gross or you feel embarrassed for the
characters it's all those emotions
adding up to this guy is in way over his
head the situation is one where he is
not supposed to be here
uh he said
the sex scene is portrayed in such a
gluttonous way because Tedros can't
believe he's there you look at him and
this is a score Jocelyn might be the
biggest score he's ever had it's very
obvious he's over indulging he walks
into this house looking around like
goddamn and my way over my head this
could be the biggest job I've ever done
um okay
I don't know what to say like
yeah like I guess sure he could explain
why this scene is is the way that it is
and his you know I'm sure in the context
of the show I don't watch the show but
I'm sure in the concept context of the
show his explanation makes a lot of
sense for his character right
but here's the thing
like why why do they have to make the
show like I know and you know it
literally is like the viewership is
through the roof I think they had more
um
people tune into the second episode than
they did like the premiere of euphoria I
think it was like 3.3 million people
like this is what people want like what
it's like a disgusting show oh I didn't
see that that it's actually performing
well yeah I had like people were being
like the show's flopping the show's
flopping and then I saw like a Nielsen
rating and it was [__] high
sounds like it's the same amount of
people as succession finale
right succession finale was like what
four well I can understand why people
want to like they hear about this
there's a curiosity sex scene there's a
curiosity so people will watch it who
knows if this will hook them enough to
keep watching it
but everything I see this show just like
gives me the willies the Willy every
time I go to Max to watch Love and Death
like it keeps coming up and it's just
like
it just gives me the willies yeah and
there's like a part of me that
definitely wanted to watch it because
I'm really intrigued by Lily Rose Depp
as just like a young Starlet
um
but she plays a young Starlet and she's
like this young Starlet who's like
being exploited and it's like very you
know dark and I don't think I want to
watch that
no me neither I I don't know I just it's
too much like
it's just too much like can't we just
like
can we just like watch nice things yeah
like can't you just put your clothes
back on like I just I just like it's too
why does everything have to be so like I
feel like with shows it's been like
slowly
you know we'll see a scene that would
like I feel like when we used to watch
girls there would be like a scene that
everyone was about that was like so
crazy but it was like one scene out of a
whole show and now it's like with each
show that comes up it's like we're
getting used to more and more and like
now it's just like straight porn no I
completely agree like it used to be
um like when you think of like sex in
the city which was like the most racy
show in the context of like today's
climate it's like not even that crazy no
like we never even saw a penis in
actually maybe you do see penis in Sex
and city but not on the E reruns no
because I watch it on HBO Max oh okay
you might like there's probably like six
pairs of tits every episode there might
be like three penises in the whole
franchise like it's so crazy
no that was like the most racy show of a
generation and it's like
in today's context it's like a team show
Child's Play yeah like we're just look I
just this is not me judging this is just
me asking like where actually where do
we draw the line like are we keep going
so far we keep going
it's like why does every show have to be
like so sexy yeah but I do don't get me
wrong like I like it in a few yeah no
and I feel like it's like sometimes it
adds value
you know they like to push the
the limits but I feel like with this
show the idol it's kind of the first
time people are like calm the [__] down
yeah people are looking around and being
like how did we get here
how did we get here how do we get out
literally
[Laughter]
we used to give them something to see oh
baby look at us that's literally what
that song is about yeah
well we'll see what happens with this
show
yeah it's
yeah I'm curious if the ratings are high
just because there's like a curiosity
and people's interests have been peaked
because the show has been described as
like really dark really weird and that's
when you see these headlines that's like
the weekend and Lily Rose Jeff are
having like literal sex on screen like
people are gonna go and watch that yeah
yeah but that's not a sustainable
business model no and that's not like a
television show right where it's like a
story being told yeah yeah
okay our next story a little comedy news
oh yeah Amy Schumer is roasting
sociopath Hilaria Baldwin's fake
Heritage and Von Trapp amount of kids in
her new Netflix special so Amy Schumer
is going after Hilaria in her new
Netflix special emergency contact while
doing a comedy set about parenting and
motherhood
Amy recalled the fact that Hilaria from
Espana is actually Hillary from Boston
Schumer reminded her audience that the
former yoga instructor the wife of
troubled actor Alec Baldwin is in no way
Spanish her parents are not from Spain
no one in her life is from Spain despite
hailing for Massachusetts Hilaria gave
her Von trap amount of children very
Spanish names like Jamon and croquetta
and Flamenco she joked
then she shared viewer she was not
trying to bully a sociopath and instead
pointed out that both Hilaria and Alex
simply don't give a [__] not only about
making up a cultural identity but also
about fatally shooting the rust
cinematographer Helena Hutchins yes
hell she did not hold back
in this like this when talking about
ilari and Alec which was actually
refreshing because people have seemed to
move on but like I'm right where you
left me I'm still thinking about the
fact that and there's not a day that
goes by that I don't think about how
[__] weird it is what she did oh how
you say uh cucumber like are you okay
is the special out yeah it came out
yesterday I'm actually gonna watch it
I've kind of been like loving Amy
Schumer ever since the Oscars me too not
since the Oscars well I always love Amy
Schumer and she's literally Dana's
favorite comedian so like I'll always
like her because she brings Dana so much
joy but she's just like really funny
sometimes and yeah no I never I actually
really always liked her movies but I
never really got into her stand up it
was just like never uh she was never
just a female comedian I was like you
know drawn to watching and Dana was
always like Jamie Schumer I'm like yeah
okay whatever and I think like for a
while I was like oh Amy Schumer is just
like so overrated but she's kind of not
she's kind of like really funny no like
she just fell into that trap where she
was so talented like we used to watch uh
like Dana and I Inside Amy Schumer we
saw Amy Schumer at MSG she came out with
like a few movies that were so so good
and so she went from being like a
mid-sized comedian to just being like
insanely huge and like anything else
kind of the expectation was greater than
the result and I feel like she got kind
of stuck in the mud for a few years but
that's an amazing like way of putting it
but she inherently is so talented and so
funny and I like her comedy a lot and I
think you would like it too because
sometimes like your comedy reminds me of
her and yeah Noah I plan on watching her
special
um
and her movies like she needs to make
more movies not enough people talk about
I feel pretty like it's literally she
had some flops so like that like what
snatched with Goldie Hawn there are
mother-daughter Duo who get kidnapped oh
I I never even heard of this film yeah
no there are I think there was another
one too but I feel like I feel like
she's been in movies and then she's like
created movies I feel like train wreck
and I feel pretty are like her and Judd
Apatow like doing everything yeah and
then maybe she got cast in this other
movie like it doesn't feel like an Amy
Schumer project I think it was an Amy
Schumer project damn it was it was an
Amy Schumer production
yeah I'm trying to
confirm that
yeah you know this Goldie Hawn movie
like does feel familiar yeah did you see
it I did see it and it was always parts
of it no and it was not good damn
yeah that's what happens like you start
doing well and then they put you in
crapola because they think that you can
save everything they think that people
like you enough that this movie will be
good and people will go and see it
yeah and you know she was on watch
Robin's live recently talking about
Barbie
and I actually thought what she said was
interesting she's like the Barbie that
um like we just all saw the trailer for
is like not the Barbie I was cast in and
that's why I left like it was like a
weird movie and I think there were like
a lot of changes happen I don't even
know if Greta Gerwig was on for the one
that Amy Schumer was in but she
basically said like this movie looks
good and the one that I was casting like
did not
yeah cause we cause we talked about how
she did that that's what we were told
like it was going to be Amy Schumer and
she's like kicked out of Barbie land
she's like Will Ferrell and elf and then
we heard that like it's no longer Amy
and that the movie premise was changing
but like honestly and I love Margot
Robbie and obviously like she's
quintessential Barbie but the idea of
like Amy Schumer playing Outcast Barbie
from Barbie land like sounds unreal no
it sounds hysterical is the movie
supposed to be a comedy
I think so okay
how does it not accommodate
I don't know is it like rated PG-13 is
isn't Barbie for kids like
it's yeah I don't think it's for kids
this isn't like Barbie this isn't Barbie
for kids but like Mattel has to
like approve you know of the content you
know what I mean yeah it's rated PG-13
okay what was elf rated
I feel like it was like literally rated
PJ I feel like
uh
uh I'm looking I'm looking
PG so cute yeah so that's like a perfect
movie because it really is like a funny
film no matter who you are like I'm sure
as a kid we thought it was hysterical
but now like as an adult like it's still
funny yeah
and that's kind of what I thought Barbie
was gonna be but Barbie's like a little
bit more raunchy
yeah I don't know
we'll see yeah we'll have to see there's
so many questions about this film like
are you ready for a fifth and final
story yes before we dive into Deer
toasters yes a tick tocker faked his own
death and then showed up at the funeral
in a helicopter to teach his family a
wider lesson
Jesus Christ The Tick Tucker in Belgium
faked his death before turning up at his
own funeral in a helicopter in a bid to
see who in his wider family would show
up David Barrington who goes by The Tick
Tock handle Ragnar lafoo carried out the
stun in front of mourners over the
weekend with the aid of his wife and
children who helped him orchestrate it
various Clips shared by other
tick-tockers appear to show scenes from
the day including shots of a coffin and
a memorial his also also prepared the
scene with a post saying rest in peace
Daddy I will never stop thinking about
you why is life Daddy
her dad
this Tick Tock is an older gentleman oh
I just assumed it was like a 12 year old
because this is something so dumb Nook
is also like when you hear tick tocker
no he's another gentleman he has kids he
has a large family and I guess he felt
like everyone was neglecting him so he
faked his own death to teach them a
lesson
they're at the funeral and he showed up
in a helicopter and he explained his
reasoning for the stunt he said we all
grew apart I felt unappreciated that's
why I wanted to give you a life lesson
and show you that you shouldn't wait
until someone is dead to meet up with
them in a further video he said that
though he was glad to feel loved on his
funeral day it's when we're alive that
we need to hear these things I did I did
this to start my life again with you he
addressed his wider family
so I mean it's a beautiful message
however
I do feel as though he could have you
know sent the message in a less
traumatizing way in a less traumatizing
way for sure it's very picky like no and
you know what like somebody who would do
this is deeply unwell and like no wonder
your family was ignoring you you're
probably psychotic yeah
yeah what the [__] things that someone
has to go to to do this
yeah like and this is coming from me I
live for attention I would quite
literally never do this if you felt like
no one was like answering your calls or
showing up for you or just like giving
you the love and attention you deserve I
feel like you maybe would no like I have
Scruples like I have I have limitations
like and there's you know a lot I would
do but there's a lot I wouldn't do this
is
like this will like put people in
therapy yeah
or it's all just like this elaborate
plan for a tick tock that's also what I
was thinking like
did he film the funeral it could be both
I do think that when you are like a tick
tock especially like a stunt pranks Tick
Tock you do try and think of like big
Ideas like and things that you wouldn't
like care to do if you weren't on Tick
Tock like you would just live your life
right but I think he also wanted to
teach people a lesson
well I think the lesson was learned but
it's probably not the lesson he wanted
us to learn because the lesson I'm sure
his family Learned was like damn Uncle
Brad or whatever his name is [__]
nuts and I want no part of this family
yeah
so that's what you missed
that's what the deeply unwell tick
tockers are up to abroad
[Laughter]
not so dissimilar from the deeply unwell
tick-tockers here no not dissimilar in
the slightest yeah and obviously to be
to be I see really like disturbing prank
tick tocks of just like people yeah
disturbing the piece and being men
assist to society and so it's like if
you want to just [__] with your own
family in this way like it's really not
as um
weirdly not as crazy as some of the
other stuff I've seen yeah no like
people who are menaces to society and
like do public pranks and like I hate
people like that it's the lowest form of
like content it's a such a low bar for
comedy like I hate that [__] yeah
um I want to dive into your toasters but
before we do I have like such an
exciting announcement that I've like
forgotten to tell everyone
please tell us do I know yeah yeah
so we recently relaunched our website
thetosepodcast.com and what's so
exciting about that is like you know you
can check out your gorgeous girls recent
episodes yada yada but there's also now
a submission page for um your toaster so
of course you can still email dear
toasters gmail.com but if you head to
our website which is the
toastpodcast.com you could just scroll
down and there's a little box where you
could type in your submission for deer
toasters and it'll get sent straight to
us so new website new submission form
but you can still submit the old way
isn't that exciting thanks
so you're saying done the new way
submitted the old way
that's exactly what I'm saying I love
that I'm so excited I was actually just
on our website yesterday like taking a
look around and what did you think I
thought it was really premium stuff but
also just like exactly what you need to
know about your girlies in the show
right it's no frills
yeah it's just like straight to the
point it's not like clickbait we want
you to spend time on our website like
for our ads like just no here are the
things that you need
exactly
um all right are you ready for deer
toasters I am
well it's brought to you by game time
buying tickets for your favorite events
should not be stressful game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over tickets and
start getting hyped for the fun you'll
actually have once you get there you
guys know this is like my summer of
concerts game time is my best friend
this summer I feel like um in I live in
New York so you know we're really
spoiled with concerts and theater and
sports so it's so great to have if
you're traveling somewhere the app is
great to just have on your phone so that
you know you have a night off in
Charlotte go see the Bobcats you know so
game time is the place for any last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the
concert or the event you get exclusive
Flash Deals on tickets for football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more the game time guarantee
means you'll always get the best price
if you find tickets in the same section
and row for Less game time will credit
you 110 of the difference so it's the
fastest growing ticket app in the
country for a reason you're getting
images of your seat before you buy you
know exactly what to expect when you
arrive you can buy tickets in a matter
of seconds it's two Taps and you're all
set the tickets are then sent directly
to your phone so you never have to dig
through your email snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account on the game time app
and redeem code toast for twenty dollars
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed so we're always talking about
seed so many people are obsessed with
seed if you have any sort of gut issue
you want when wanting to get into a
probiotic or a Prebiotic check out seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic it is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strain
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
it's free from 14 classes of allergens
that are defined by the efsa so that
includes sugar-free vegan soy free
Sesame free gluten-free peanut free ampa
free dairy-free shellfish free corn
frame you basically take two capsules
once a day on an empty stomach so that
could be the first thing in the morning
or two hours after your last meal and
it's engineered to survive to your
external and internal environments if
you've taken or experimented with
different probiotics and you haven't
felt like it works that's why seed is
different their capsule and capsule via
cap safeguards viability through
digestion for delivery of an average of
100 of their probiotics starting dose to
your colon the outer capsule also serves
as an elegant barrier to oxygen moisture
and heat plus there's no Refrigeration
necessary there's so many benefits of
seeds dso1 daily symbiotic of course
Digestive Health you can you know make
smooth more regular Perfection duties
also there's a lot of skin benefits your
skin Health the dso1 daily symbiotic has
four specific probiotic strains that
have been shown to promote healthy skin
and reinforce a healthy skin gut access
so it's the cds01 daily symbiotic get
the real deal in symbiotic one that's
backed by clinical trials and scientific
data visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to redeem 30 off your first month
of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic that's
seedseed.com toast code toast alright
are you ready for deer toasters I am I
am
hey Jackson Claude my boyfriend and I
have been together for almost three
years and we've been living together for
two throughout the past six months my
boyfriend has chosen to sleep almost
every night alone in the guest room
occasionally on the weekends he'll sleep
in our bed with me but those times have
gotten few and far between he likes to
play video games late at night and says
he doesn't want to wake me up by coming
to bed late I told him that it really
upsets me and I actually wouldn't mind
him coming to bed late as long as he
comes to bed eventually and I get to
wake up next to him he says I'm trying
to take away too much of his personal
time and it shouldn't matter because
when we are asleep it's not valuable
quality time he doesn't understand why
I'm upset that we aren't sleeping in the
same bed and he makes me feel like I'm
asking for too much I've tried bringing
this up to him multiple times and the
conversation never ends well am I
overreacting or am I asking for too much
what should I do thanks a lonely toaster
that is this is weird this is weird
something's weird about it that he's
like in so insistent on sleeping in the
guest room even though his reasons for
not sleeping with you would be like
things that you should decide whether or
not you bother you okay with
um yeah there's definitely another
reason
so Random I actually just read I was
almost going to choose it as a story
yesterday this woman you know she's like
me and my husband have the perfect
marriage we live in separate Burrows and
I know that there are like people who
you know sleep in separate beds or
literally even have separate homes I
think like Jackie gold Schneider's
parents literally live in separate
houses like I know that there's things
and whatever works for whatever marriage
but like if you are saying like you want
a partner who sleeps in bed with you
like and that's a non-negotiable you are
so not asking for a lot that's extremely
valid and yeah you don't spend quality
time when when you sleep with someone
but like any night I'm sleeping alone
like there's a there's a loneliness like
I totally get it you're not you're so
justified in what you're asking for and
I feel like the video game thing like is
not a real answer that was like his
cover and you saying it doesn't bother
you like definitely [__] with him so I
feel like I feel like maybe he's doing
something in his sleep like maybe it's
like jerking off like I don't know like
I think there's like something he's not
telling you yeah I would try and find
out what the reason is but also yes some
couples live separately or whatnot but
that's after like Decades of marriage
where you're just like uh like set in
your way please and want your space and
you've earned it but after being in a
relationship for two years like you
shouldn't have to be sleeping alone
especially if you don't want to be so I
would try and find the source of the
issue because it sounds like he's coming
up with a bunch of excuses like I don't
know maybe he pees the bed something
yeah you know there's he's hiding
something
yeah he's hiding something he is yes
maybe he plays his video games and it's
like an episode of Black Mirror and he's
having an affair in the video game and
then he doesn't feel comfortable like
going to sleep with you oh my God it's
so Black Mirror it's so Landry it's so
metaverse
yeah no this is weird um I don't think
it has anything to do with the video
games and my advice would be to like
actually figure out what it is but he
sounds like so close closed off and like
borderline immature it's like you want
to sleep with your girlfriend you're
playing video games like you sound like
a teenager yeah and like maybe that
could I would imagine that would show
through in other areas of the
relationship so I would I would not like
brush this off and also you know get
into a relationship to sleep alone like
that's one of the perks of being in a
loving relationship is like you have
someone to go to bed with and you know
pillow talk as a model and like those
are the good times sleep is honestly for
me like a quality time like I did with
him no and also the and the fact that
like you're going to bed every night
alone and not getting that quality time
like the time before bed like when you
watch TV or you talk or you just like
both read in silence like that's the
definition of quality time so him not
sleeping with you while the sleeping
might not be quality time it's all the
the activities around the sleep like
waking up and going to sleep that are
like best parts of a relationship and
you're missing out on that yeah so I
would push the issue for sure
for sure there's something else going on
don't let this because then you'll just
get into a place where it's like it is
what it is and you find yourself you
know with someone for 10 years and
you're never sleeping together and
you're missing out on that and if that's
important to you
then don't that's not something that you
should have to compromise on
and it being important to you is so
valid like you're not overreacting
you're not asking for too much right but
there's also other people who this would
not be important to them and it's like
oh sweet I get to be in a relationship
but I still get a whole ass bed to
myself Best of Both Worlds right but
like if one of if one person in the
relationship like wants to sleep
together then we're both sleeping
together yeah
no I'm not into this like new age
separate Burrows it's actually not that
new age like in downtown they had
separate rooms we're kind of like going
back
yeah I guess I guess that's actually
fair but but in Downton they were doing
the societal norm and now the societal
Norm is to sleep together yeah
yeah
and the couples that were really in love
would always like sneak around and sleep
together it's so true and also that was
only really for the aristocracy to sleep
separate like it's not like every like
all people were doing that no you're
right like the the staff who were
married were sleeping in the same bed
yeah or just like middle class or lower
class people like they weren't having
separate bedrooms yeah it's a it's a
luxury not many could afford yeah all
right ready for our next one um hey
Jackson Dirty long time listener first
time writer I'll get right into it my
boyfriend is 24 and we've been dating
for a few years pjom everything of the
sort yada yada except whenever he says
goodbye to his mom he kisses her on the
mouth this weirds me out I have two
older brothers and I've never seen them
kiss my mom but I don't know how to
approach him about it without making his
mom upset what if she thinks I'm a Naggy
[__] girlfriend because I'm controlling
her son or he thinks I'm out of pocket
for this am I crazy for thinking this
please help sincerely a toaster who
doesn't kiss their mom
candidate because I don't have a boy son
no actually the opposite like you kiss
Harry on the mouth more than I do I
won't be doing that when he has a
girlfriend he's a baby I was gonna I
don't know like what one day you're just
gonna stop
there will come a time where like it
won't be like normal and it will be
weird like I won't do it okay so you're
saying it's not cool for adults to kiss
their parents no so here's the thing I'm
I feel like neither of us can really
truly answer this fairly because we do
kiss our mom on the lips like I don't
know actually if you do but I do like I
don't think it's weird but like we're
all girls so I have to imagine if I had
a father who was alive I would not be
kissing him on the mouth but I would
probably still be kissing my mom I think
it's a gender thing interesting
so if this girl's boyfriend was kissing
his dad on the lips that would be fine
no no no no no sorry okay here and these
are my rules okay
there's no engagement
and there's no Rhyme or Reason I'm not
saying they're right but this is what I
think is normal okay girls can kiss
their moms on the lip girls cannot kiss
their dads on the lip boys cannot kiss
their moms on the lip boys cannot kiss
their dads on the lips
okay
so just like a mother daughter so just
the thing
[Laughter]
the thing yes
I don't know
I don't know I mean I I imagine I would
feel the same way that this girl feels
like seeing it yeah this is
unequivocally bizarre but like I don't
know if as a mama like if I if I'm going
to be insisting on kissing Harry on the
lips when he's a grown man
yeah right I don't think I will be
because that's just really not who I am
right that's the thing that's why it's
also not fair because like you also are
just not like a kisser yeah but like Tom
Brady and his kids like when they would
kiss on the lips and stuff and people
would be quaking what were your thoughts
when Tom Brady was kissing his kids
I definitely thought it was weird but
not I don't think I actually don't think
it's weird
but when Tom Brady was kissing his own
dad I thought that was weird
I don't think so
I think you either do it like it's
either normal in your household or it's
not yeah like but it's not like if you
do it like it's then when people make it
weird that makes it weird it's like whoa
bro what are you thinking like we just
like no I know it's like parent but like
your boyfriend's kissing another woman
like
oh my God
no this is like a really gray area like
it's personal there's not a rule like
what I said is just what I think but
you're right it's clearly reflected
reflected off of my own life experience
like I Ben doesn't kiss either of his
parents on the lips so this is not I
really honestly for the first time in my
life like I'm truly stomped I know me
too
I don't know if it's worth saying
something because you kind of just like
look crazy like what you're jealous of
his mom no you look crazy and if the mom
found out that you had ah and then how
does how does he go from kissing his mom
his whole life to not yeah and like
she's gonna think she did something
wrong that you just have to wince every
time you see it and that's your cross to
bear
yeah and I guess like you can talk to
your partner about it
and tell him that like you think it's
weird without asking him to do anything
but just like vocalizing yourself so
that like every time he does it he gets
a pit and maybe he'll do it less
yeah like you deserve to be heard your
feelings are valid
right yeah this is just like one of
those things like how it's just like
hard and weird to merge families because
people have different customs and people
were just like raised so differently
even people who were raised similar at
its core like even you know people who
were raised in the same town same
religion same whatever like even like
similar people have differences in how
they were raised in like customs and
stuff so
but I do feel like if something bothers
you like it's never a bad thing to speak
your truth without asking for anything I
don't think everything that bothers a
person needs to be spoken
oh that's actually so true
honestly I'm I'm truly stumped I really
don't know
I would like people to sound off in the
comments yeah yeah maybe you've been
through something similar
yeah and you've had like either a good
outcome or something you've swallowed
this is where we need to rely on our
Network yeah
that's so true it's beyond us we're
limited in our knowledge of this and I
have literally like no nothing even
remotely similar in my life experience
to like hark back to yeah I agree
toasters sound off
great sound off one two all right are
you ready for our third and final deer
toasters I'm ready
hey Jackson Claude I feel bad even
sharing this but I have to get it off my
chest and get some advice my boyfriend
recently shared with me that he's super
self-conscious about his nipples because
they're quote puffy and they make him
look overweight if you Google puffy
nibbles you'll understand what I mean
it's definitely a genetic thing
considering his brother has them too I
feel weird even looking at his brother's
nipples
anyways he recently discovered these
little bandages that cover them up and
make his chest look more normal under
shirts since then he's had to rip them
off when his shirt comes off when we're
getting intimate
and that act gives me the creeps it
honestly ruins the mood when he has to
turn around rip the bandages off and
then get back to whatever we were doing
he's such a supportive King whenever I
feel self-conscious so I don't want to
make him feel bad but I'm really getting
the ick about this please help a girl
out over these nipples every piece of
advice is welcome
wow another one that is so tough
I think this is something you gotta
swallow
really yeah because you said like he's
such a supportive King anything about
your body you feeling self-conscious and
you know what I think for a guy to admit
like that something's bothering him and
then to like actually do something about
it is a level of vulnerability that is
we should admire and we should encourage
that so you then to be like it grosses
me out like you know what you could tell
him leave on leave him on or like I
don't know if it's is it the act of
ripping them off I think is it active
ripping in them off the reminder that
they're there and the the break in
the flow of sexy time yeah to do this I
understand what she's saying completely
oh by the way I completely understand
but I'm saying like for the health and
sanctity of your relationship like I do
think you just have to get over it
and maybe because it's new it's giving
you the ick and once it becomes
customary like you'll forget about it
but I think like you should really try
to look past it honestly
that's really you're asking a lot
I know but imagine the destruction to
his self-confidence and she actually
sits him down and says it I know
like no why are these so hard today no I
know it's like is it us or is it are
these queries no these queries are
particularly
um divisive and dear toasters woke up
today and chose violence like I I feel
like in the last one I really had
absolutely no idea what to say in this
one I feel like you should you should
you have to like work on getting over it
I actually feel strongly about that what
if you like suggested you guys shower
before
every time not every time but maybe like
maybe eventually he'll stop wearing them
like maybe he's just going through a
phase yes being so you just have to get
over this patch but if you were like
let's shower so then he has to take them
off first and then you can like properly
enter
the routine
yeah I guess but like that seems so
strategic and kind of calculating when
you could just learn to accept it like
honestly
I I really feel like
like I get it like I just want to say
I'm not judging it if I completely get
the ick if they hurt to take off and so
it's like yeah if he has hairs around
his nipple yeah
yeah how are you supposed to go from
like being in the moment then like
watching someone rip off what's
essentially like a really painful
Band-Aid
no two of them
why doesn't he leave them on is that
more of a nick
like nipples for men are like not like a
big deal yeah you could say just leave
it babe
try yeah yeah try that's a good one
this was tough honestly like
this stuff but like I you have our
sympathies honestly like you're in a
pickle and and I feel you're in a pickle
but you're a good girlfriend that you
even care enough to like
want to protect his feelings yeah I just
I don't think you'll ever really regret
like just ignoring it but I do think if
you say something like you might regret
it like because like he might feel so
self-conscious you know it's like set
off
yeah a chain reaction
yeah I don't think you will regret not
bringing it up
no but that that depends on like what
kind of person you are like and there's
no right or wrong answer but like would
you rather be uncomfortable about
something or would you rather like be
fine with something but no I had to know
that someone else is uncomfortable about
something
wait phrase the question like would you
rather be uncomfortable
or have the other person be
uncomfortable and you are fine and
you're like me me you'd rather because
you're the uncomfortable one because
then if we're both uncomfortable not
only am I uncomfortable but I'm also
then double uncomfortable knowing like
what is he thinking yeah no I agree I'm
the same way
um but everyone's different
I think I think based on our
conversation I think you have to get
over it
and tell him he doesn't need to take him
off
or maybe like when he's taking them off
like you go
do something quickly like for yourself
so you don't have to catch a snack fetch
a snack pee something like yeah yeah put
on music
yeah every time you take them off you go
to put on music
yeah I'm curious if the nipples bothered
you before you know he got them taped up
didn't sound like it yeah
interesting I'm sticking firm
I like this solution of busy yourself
during that time with something that's a
mood enhancer to counteract the mood D
enhancer also very good advice a candle
a sexy playlist
yeah
oils start massaging his back while he
rips at his front
isn't that good that is good
um thank you everyone was actually
deeply vulnerable with us this week so
we really appreciate it reminder if you
want to submit there are now two ways
deer toasters at gmail.com or head over
to thechosepodcast.com scroll down
there's a dear deer toaster submission
box that's our show tomorrow we are in
studio with Ben Soffer boy with no job
good guys host founder of Spritz CEO and
founder so don't miss that we'll be back
on YouTube then thank you so much for
listening to the test on Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the faster stories
you need to know everybody watching this
on YouTube please don't be subscribe
give this video thumbs up russellville's
podcasting events
until sleep first review about a
beautiful setting a wicked what talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing
Wednesday happy hump day don't forget to
hump someone you love and we'll see
chimero love you bye